(dramatic music)
- Please settle
down, settle down.
Yes, the rumors are true
the boy is still missing.
I know we all want him back,
but we still have
a handful of leads,
I will now go to the
press for any questions.
- Hi, Chett Ripley, MSNBC.
Is the boy's father a suspect?
- We cannot comment on the
suspect list at this time.
Uh, yes?
- Hey man, how's it going,
Bob Newman, Buzzfeed News.
- Right, I should
say this right now,
we are treating
blogs as news now
so they are allowed in
the pressroom, go ahead.
- Yeah, would you
say that this case
is something only kids from
the 90's would understand?
- No.
- Cupcakes and Cashmere
lifestyle blog,
my coffee is too hot,
will you blow on it?
- Next question.
- Hunter Chuckman,
Alaskan Salmon Daily,
does this case have anything
to do with Alaskan Salmon?
- No!
- Branson Rothchild,
ShippersDelight.tumblr.com.
- Okay...
- Are you and the boys father
crushing on each other?
- Are we crushing on each other?
I don't know what that--
no, no we're not crushing.
- But I have pages of fan art
that would suggest otherwise,
so this is you--
- We're not talking about fan--
we're talking about--
this is, guys, we need
serious questions!
This is a serious situation.
- Bloop bloop bloop!
- Oh, boy.
Seymour Glass with
BananaFish.boink.
I represent an online
humorous magazine,
that caters mostly to
weirdos in basements,
what is your fart?
- I don't know
what, I don't know
how to answer that question.
- James Franco for
James Franco's Instagram,
ou- t Jaofme hs erFrean
t
cor
- Get outta here James Franco!
This is what I'm
talking about alright!
A child is missing, I need
serious questions, please!
- Hunter Chuckman, does
now the case have anything
to do with Alaskan salmon?
- It has nothing to do
with Alaskan Salmon!
- No more dead cops!
[crowd cheers]
- That's from The Dark Knight.
- Why won't Hollywood
cast Jessica Biel anymor
- Continuity.com,
this lady is now sitting
where that lady was
sitting earlier.
- 40 year old
Splurchin.com.
- BigBootyMILFS.hellyeah.
- TwoBestBuds.com!
- FingerBlast.gov.
- FugeddaBoutIt.com!
9/11 was an inside job!
- Goddamit, shut up!
(audience talking loudly)
- Shut up, shut up, shut up!
Now listen to me, I
understand that this is
where the press is
headed, but if you guys
can't take a
situation seriously,
how are we supposed
to take you seriously?
Now does anybody in this room
have an actual
question, what is it?
- Where was the boy last seen?
- Thank God you're here.
The boy was last seen at
the Sunshine Cafe eating a,
I wanna make sure
I get this right,
bagel with...
Alaskan Salmon.
- Yeah! Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Well, golly, golly,
that's the scoop!